congratulations that's fantastic and so
did you bring your medals with you no we
did you might be wearing them although
they're just casually in the back pocket
Wow was it French people Beecher oh the
French [ __ ] is there anyone in Ireland
who hasn't seen those medals Michael
down in Killarney word must have reached
you off the Adhan oh for sure I mean I
wasn't in Killarney at the time but
that's for sure yeah yeah and Marian
watching that clip on that could you
understand the accents nothing I
understood is the chick Carrie acts
because the people people loved the
interviews you did the Olympics but like
you guys knew you were being funny while
you're the hugeness I don't know yeah we
want to just serious like but yeah and
just yeah you didn't seem very happy to
be in Rio it's quite serious about the
one situation when every time we told is
the truth like yeah I understand though
people ask us these questions aren't the
time after races it just so happened
they put a camera in front of us in Rio
you want a silver medal this thing is
this is like Ireland has never won any
medal in rowing before have they not
Olympics know a few World Championship
titles all right Buddhist the first
Olympic medal yeah aunty interview where
you talked about your approach to the
race the phrases you used in that so
explain to the people what you what you
said in that going a to be fast you can
yeah this is a fairly simple sport like
[Music]
complicated like your menses go out to
start and there's a to finish this thing
about closing your eyes and pull like a
dog yeah so that phrase who came up with
that is that phrase it's everywhere now
in Ireland yeah yeah like you'd be
walking down the street there and in
Dublin or somewhere in a village so the
faster or chilly
[Laughter]
have you ever had a man but of your
desired sex tell you to pull like a dog
the questions are getting harder
but but wasn't there a guy came up to
you in a in a just right so the trailer
came up to pylons so in a annoyed
comments the marine like and yeah what
tattoo yeah like right improperly like
ink tattoo like crisis pool for I'm
saying put like a dog that was not like
[Applause]
Marianna just as well
missing nothing so now we've got a
picture of you this is this is the the
day you came back to Sookie buried yeah
so like amazing
[Applause]
if you haven't been discovery and a lot
of people world to be discovery you know
it's not a big town peoples it's my
little town the population is about
fifteen hundred people and they're
saying there was about fifteen toes and
turned up to the homecoming it wasn't
crazy like presumably you're never going
to have to buy a drink again the same
two fellows like Don Skibbereen and Ed
have no respect for anything no nearly
yeah no yeah we get cherished away in
screen anyway that's not because you
know it's sport it's a lot of discipline
a lot of training and now that there's
kind of all the kind of the fun side of
things the you know traveling around you
know people recognize if you bring up to
your nightclubs um not exactly
and so is it gonna be harder to kind of
get back in the boat in order to see if
you like to you just put the board
[Applause]
[ __ ] great sometimes we just hasn't
moved
[Music]